it's a remarkable how long I've known
you but you see to me you're still a kid
I'm so good yeah and we talked about
also um just the crushing when Manhattan
love story got canceled crushing
depression yeah I watched it you I like
that girl
the Connelly yeah yeah me too I liked on
the venom Steve Carell movie yes she's
been a lot of she's like had a really
incredible career but like people don't
realize that you you test I mean I hate
when we talk about show business on the
show but I have well you you know
audition for something they call you
back then they call you back again and
then you have to do a studio test and
then you do a network test and before
the network has to tell you how much
you're making while you sign something
they the money you see the money you're
buying things in your in your head it's
like ridiculous amount psychologically
psychologic what like my life could
change and then you actually get the
show and then you do a pilot which
rarely gets picked up so you're winning
all these little lotteries right and the
final lottery is it for this thing to
stay on for seven years
oh my god that's imagine I know yeah
that's and you're there so I was on
animal practice you had done you know
man I love story and you're now you have
one final hurdle and then it gets
canceled no I understand that
you know boohoo right but to us it's
crushing it is I would cry it's
incredible the disappointment and that
nobody cares everybody's like all right
on to the next like yeah network we're
moving on no the time to us yeah and
you're working together with these
people they become your family your I
was with these people for half a year
every single day all day yeah go to New
York I'm had to get an apartment New
York yeah buy all the furniture
everything yeah and it just ended like
hey it's done yes sorry and it was
everywhere the cancellation was really
it was the first one cancelled of the
year
oh my god oh my god you cried you you
said for many years
yeah them two years now it's done for me
I was with Betsy sodaro love Betsy I
love Betsy so Betsy Ann are sitting
there on set today for animal practice
and the Russo brothers coming on now the
Russo brothers directed the second and
third community no Civil War but Captain
America will be another action and
they're amazing movies they got rated
high you know so they're boohead moved
on but at that time they had done
community and they had done animal
practice right so the Russo brothers
walk together Joe and Anthony on set
already I know there's something wrong
because you never saw them together you
never see judge that only comes once a
year you know I mean and then you never
see him again
right and you know that it's a 9/11
situation is as if you know the Russo
brothers showed up as soon as they
walked up on stage I turned that Betsy
and I said we're getting cancelled her
lip trembled
I got we're getting canceled and one day
and it made the announcement right Betsy
Sarah's head is facing the ground right
you can see people just disheveled me
tears coming down because I hadn't
worked since MADtv and I was like a
six-year hiatus yeah and the Rolling
Stones had done an article saying that
this is their last chance these actors I
still have it so they said every single
Tyler Labine just just incorrect Bobby
Lee this is their last chance because
Tyler Labine still had I know I
understand that but that's what I want
to know how was them how did the monkey
take the news he's busy yeah how did you
find out I was I came home after working
all day it was like 6:30 la time I was
on my couch and my agent called and said
it's over it's done I go what's done I
have no idea like literally didn't even
my brain just did it and it was my
boyfriend had just started SNL
which you got I don't know if you guys
have heard rumors but in yeah the most
intense like all involving like he was
spending the night there almost every
night like it's you know so I didn't
have it's the most insane work
environment of all no the show got
canceled nobody was saying anything but
I could tell that and then there was a
joke actually once on SNL about failed
sitcoms and nobody warned me and we're
all watching the show and it got like a
big laugh in the writers room and I was
like so it's you know it's it's a
devastating thing but and then and then
you go to your regular life and you do
the road and then you do these you know
you play some rooms that seat 200 seats
and you can only get 40 people in the
room that's it right and you know like
the club manager and the you know or
like they're all depressed because
they're making no one's making any money
and you're in the back right
contemplating suicide or like some sort
of thing you know
also this club didn't have a bathroom I
could use unless you cross the entire
audience it was like is it like an old
theater it's an old theater with just a
bunch of office chairs literally like
I'm not exaggerating it's a great room
it really is huge it's huge it's called
the Arlington Draft House and it's
family-run and um I'm gonna play it for
the rest of my life if they happen yeah
my family was right there so I was like
yes they treat you so good and they're
like family and the DC improv I played
but they didn't want to pay me any money
so I moved on and Arlena Draft House are
very generous and fair and that's all we
want as performers yeah a place where I
can pee or take a poop right before I go
onstage that's like my thing that I do
and I both times I couldn't take a poop
it was very difficult for me yeah
[Music]